انتم في الخرطوم كنتوا نعم مين كانت
الاوضاع صعب انا اتحدث الى احد يعني
الاخوان الاردنيين الذين وصلوا اول شيء
اتعرف عليك عبد الجليل عصام عرفه ونعم
الحمد لله على السلامه اولا كيف كيف كانت
الرحله سهله ولا تغلبت ومتعبه الحمد لله
نوعا ما ممتازه يعني الشباب ما شاء الله
ما قصروا طواله وصلنا المطار على طول
عملوا لنا الدخول وطلعنا على الطياره
والحمد لله امورنا تمام نقلكم برا من
الخرطوم الى وبعد ذلك بالطائرات احكي لنا
بس شوي ايش التفاصيل بدي اسمع منك ايش
الاوضاع هناك لانه الناس حابه تسمع ايش
اللي بصير فعلا على الاراضي اللي
السودانيه والشيء الوضع كان جدا صعب القصه
صارت فجاه يعني كنا نشعر بتوتر خوف
بس يعني زي ما تولدت ساعه الصفر فجاه
من المعارك من القصف من بيتي كان جنب
المطار بالضبط منطقه اسمها بري ببعد عن
المطار تقريبا اثنين كيلو بس يعني باخر
الشارع بكون شايف المطار الرئيسي
اللي بنسمعه انه في جثث بالشوارع في قتل
كثير في جثث في يعني حتى واحنا مروحين على
الطريق كان في يعني لاحظنا لبعض الجثث على
الشارع بس مش واضح ملامحها لكن انا نص جثه
جثه هيك مش باينه تعاليمها واغلبها محروقه
يعني للاسف بس يعني اوضاع قصف صعب يعني عن
جد ما ما حصل في احنا شفنا هذا الحكي في
الخرطوم او في السودان مع عهدنا عليها هذا
الحكي يعني بس الوضع كتير كان صعب والحمد
لله رب العالمين لو بدك توصف الاوضاع من
حيث الامان الان في الخرطوم بصراحه كيف
توصفها في لو فيها امان ما جينا
يعني كنا سبنا سياراتنا مصارينا
بزنس تبعنا شغلنا كلنا طلعنا باوعينا بس
يعني هاي يمشون الحمد لله
الله يعطيك العافيه الحمد لله على السلامه
بالنسبه لرحله الطيران مع السلاح الجو
الملكي كيف كانت ما شاء الله يعني مجرد
شوفتنا لهم في المطار كل الكل صار يضحك
يعني كل الابتسامه ابتسمت على وجوه الكل
يعني خلص حسينا نحن وصلنا الاردن الحمد
لله على السلامه الحمد لله على السلامه
نورت سرور ومعروف يعني
ملكا وقائدا وشعبا للنشاما النشامى وين ما
نروح الحمد لله الحمد لله على السلامه
طاهر هذه شهاده احد الاخوان الحمد لله على
سلامتكم اردنيين من وين اجيتوا اي مدينه
احنا جينا من الخرطوم برضو الخرطوم انت
طالب هناك لا لا احنا مستثمرين انا ابن
مستثمر هنا كلنا عشرين سنه موجودين
بالسودان طيب انا سمعت للاخ هناك كرتونه
احنا غاد اسمه مصنع الربيع تمام بس انا
كنت استمعت للاخر بعرف انكم مرهقين متعبين
ولكن شهاداتكم مهمه بتعرف انتم شفتوا هناك
كيف الوضع هناك توصل لنا طول ما دام وصلنا
بلدنا الحمد لله احنا بنعمل ننسى التعب
بننسى كل شيء الوضع بصراحه صعب في البلد
تحكي لنا عنه من اي ناحيه كيف القصف كنت
قريب من القصف من القتل احنا بالنسبه لنا
كان القصف جنبنا يعني كويس حتى شغلنا
الضرر وصار في نهب صار في سرقه الشوارع
الجثث يعني شفت بعينك فعلا جثه اربعه ايام
ما شالوها شوف نسبه الجثث مش كبيره اها بس
موجوده وبعدين اللي بيصير انه صار في
عمليه النهب والسرقه صار في استغلال للوضع
اللي بصير يعني صح انه في قصف وصار فيه
يعني بس في نهب للبيوت للصيدليات قديش
قديش نسبه الامانه اذا بدنا نحكي نشوف
احنا بالنسبه لنا ماشيين من اول امبارح
عشان نوصلهم اه بعرف عنده خرطوم برا الى
احلى يعني كانت جايتنا خطوره وقعدتنا هناك
خطوره بس جيتنا اامن من قعدتنا يعني ممكن
انت تكون قاعد تجيك قذيفه على البيت تقصفك
وصارت فعلا وصارت كثير وصارت مع في ناس
اردنيين هون مصالحهم شغلهم تضرر بشكل كبير
الحمد لله فش اصابات في الجاليه الاردنيه
احنا يعني
الحمد لله ما في اي اصابات والامور الحمد
لله وسفارتنا الله يجزيها الخير كانت
متابعه معنا اول باول عظيم والحمد اول شيء
الحمد لله على سلامتكم ايش شعورك لما اول
ما نزلت الطياره في عمان كيف بصراحه طبعا
شعور بالامان يعني احنا قلنا اسبوع انا
طلعت على شغلي يوم السبت اللي فات لما
بدات الاحداث وبديت اشتغل ما شفت الا
هالرصاص وهالضرب وهالناس احنا اسبوع
خوف وقاعد وقاعدين بالبيت ومش قادرين
نتحرك وفي عنا وفي يعني انا في تحت يعني
معي عندي 50 شخص في الشغل جوازاتهم
واغراضهم معي انا اللي قدامك
بالخزنه لحد الان ما قدرت اخذه في تسهيل
طبعا الخارجيه لجوازاتكم بالدخول هلا بكل
شيء الله يجزيهم الخير والاردن ما بنسوا
اولاده يعني اكيد اكيد الحمد لله على
السلامه الحمد لله على السلامه الخوف راح
نتمنى للسودان الشقيق طبعا انه تكون
امورهم كلها على خير ما يرام شكرا جزيلا
طاهر طبعا هنالك قصص وحكايه كثيره نحاول
ان يعني نستمع اليها نعم الحمد لله على
السلامه
من اين اي مدينه اجيت من السودان من
الخرطوم من الخرطوم نعم نعم كيف الاوضاع
بدنا نسمع انتم شهاداتكم بعرف متعبين
مرهقين ولكن ايش اللي شفتوه اتمنى الخير
لاخواننا في الخرطوم يعني والوضع كارثي
وماساوي وفي نقص في مواد الغذائيه والنقص
في الوسائل النقل والكهرباء
ونتمنى لهم الخير اكثر من هيك ما بنقدر
نقول كنت قريب من مناطق القصف والقتال نعم
نعم في العاصمه نعم
ايش اللي قاعد بيصير على الارض الجثث
الموجوده على الارض
[موسيقى]
مش لما شفت القوات الاردنيه والقوات
المسلحه نفسيا ارتحت انه خلاص انا بين
ايدي امينه ان شاء الله يا رب وربنا
يعطيهم العافيه وما قصروا وشكرا شكرا شكرا
طاهر هذه شهادات اشخاص يعني انت تستمع
ربما طبعا هم في حاله من التعب والارباك
ربما اعمار ميسون معك عذرا ميسون معك الان
الميسون عذرا نحن ما زلنا نتابع معك وصول
ان نستمع نعم يعني نحن ايضا نريد منك اننا
نحاول فقط
الحمد لله على السلامه
من وين من اي مدينه جئت من الخرطوم برضه
كنت قريب من المناطق الاشتباكات المعارك
بعرف انت مرهق وتعبان يعطيك العافيه ولكن
انتم بتعملوا شهاده حيه حقيقيه شفتوها
هناك اشرح لنا ايش شفت ايش اللي بيصير
هناك والله الوضع صعب هناك كان القصف من
كل محل والضرب من كل محل الواحد كان في
محل الشامن يعني بالمره
طالعه من البيوت صعبه
المشتريات المواد التموينيه كلها الاشياء
هاي صعبه كانت الكهرباء مي ما كان في
موجود
شفت فعلا جثث بالشوارع الاليات محترقه شفت
معارك شفتوا هذا الاشي احنا كنا نسمع انه
في جثث في الشوارع بس احنا يعني ما طلعنا
من البيوت طيب كنت تعرضتوا مثلا لانقطاع
في المواد التموينيه فعلا فقدتوها يعني
قعدتوا ايام بدون ايام كانت تنقطعت
بطل موجود بطل كيف تدبرتوا حالكم كيف بدك
تدبر حالك كان راي الاخر اشي يعني في
الدكاكين السوبر ماركت اخر اشي يعني
وخلصوا احنا جينا في وقت مناسب جدا يعني
كان كل شيء الحمد لله على السلامه الله
يسلمك طيب رحله رحله الرحله البريه من
الخرطوم الى بورت سودان ومن ثم بالطائرات
العسكريه الى الاردن كيف كانت كيف توصفها
والله كانت صعبه لانه الطريق طويله الطريق
صعب خطره
والشارع ضيق يعني وفيها عن طريق من
الخرطوم الى بورت سودان من الخرطوم الى
بورسود نعم خطير يعني وطويل جدا
فيها تعب بس الحمد لله الان التعب والخوف
ان شاء الله بيروح انت في بوطنك يعني وصلت
امن الحمد لله على السلامه ولكن انا لو
بدي توصف لي الوضع من حيث الامان في
السودان ايش بتلخصوا كيف بتلخصوا لا حاليا
ما في امان بالمره حاليا في الوقت الحالي
وفي الوقت
صعب جدا هنا الحمد لله على السلامه انا
بدي احاول اتحدث للاخوات هنا اذا تحدثوا
الينا الحمد لله على السلامه حضرتك
اردني نعم الحمد لله من وين اي مدينه جئت
انا من الخرطوم من الخرطوم نعم من الخرطوم
مرهقين جميعا انا اعرف ذلك ولكن نسمع
واحنا طبعا في السفر والحمد لله تعدينا
طبعا للمرحله الاولى كانت الخطره في
الطريق اي مرحله من الخرطوم الى الخرطوم
الى منطقه مدني منطقه مدني طبعا تبعد 180
كيلو متر يعني والحمد لله وصلنا الى ارض
الوطن بكل الامان بس انا بدي اسمع شهادتك
في التفاصيل كيف كانت الطريق من من
الخرطوم الى مدني لانه كان في اشتباكات
الدعم السريع كان فيها الايام الماضيه
وبعدين كيف لحين وصلتوا الى بورسودان توصف
لنا الموضوع طبعا الطريق شاقه ومتعبه جدا
لكن كان مثل ما اسلفت انه مرحله الخطره
كانت من الخرطوم الى مدني بعد مدني تقريبا
وانت ذاهب الى منطقه ولايه القضارف لغايه
بعد منطق ولايه الكسلا كانت الامور لا
فعلا بعد ما خرجنا من ولايه القضاء حوالي
نصف ساعه كان هناك في قصه بالطائرات يبدو
انه كان في بعد هيك
اي نعم وبلغنا انه الحمد لله انه تم انه
وصولكم الى كسله او بنصف الطريق
امنه قبل ان يتم القصف من قبل الجيش
السوداني على الدعم السليم طيب انت حضرتك
كنت في الخرطوم كنت قريب من اماكن
الاشتباكات والقصف وشفت
ايش مشاهد ايش ايش القصف نسمعه يوميا منذ
صباح الباكر ذوي اطلاق النار وكذلك
المدفعيه وكان يعني بشكل وتيره دائما يعني
مستمر مستمره وازعاج شديد لهذا الموضوع
يعني بصراحه يعني هو يعني المنطقه فيها
كان قريبه على المطار والقياده يعني وكان
الوضع فعلا فيما
يتعلق على الدواء الغذاء الماء الكهرباء
ايضا الجثث المتواجده في الشوارع ايش
شهاداتك انت كشخص جئت من هناك ايش شفت من
هذا كله من هذا الشيء ما شفت انا الجثث
لكن
طرق الى اسمعنا هذا الشيء لكن بالنسبه
للمستشفيات فعلا الامور معدومه من ناحيه
الطبيه
وحتى لو بتحتاج الدواء الصيدليات مغلقه ما
بتقدر يعني بنفس الوقت كنا نخرج من اجل
نحصل على المؤن او نحصل على الطعام كنا
بحذر شديد خاصه بالنهار وبعد المغرب كان
الخروج يكون في خطوره جدا على الشخص يعني
ما يقدر يخرج نهائي يعني لانه بيكون
فيرسك عالي جدا حقيقه في هذا الموضوع انا
انا اهنيك اولا بالسلامه ونشكر الله ولكن
ولكن سريعا باختصار اذا بدك توصف الوضع من
حيث الامان في السودان كيف توصفه للناس
عم بيزداد سوء لحد اللحظه هاي ولا يوجد
الامان اللي نحكي فيه انه حد يقدر يامن
على نفسه حقيقه الحمد الموضوع ودعونا اول
شيء نشكر الله عز وجل على وصولنا بامان
لارض الوطن وبنشكر جلاله الملك عبد الله
الثاني من الحسين المعظم على متابعته
الحثيثه حقيقه على وتشكيل خليه الازمه من
اندلاع الحرب ومتابعه على تواصل معكم من
اللحظه الاولى وعنا احنا تطبيق على
الجاليه الاردنيه ومتابعه لكل الجاليه
الاردنيه والطلاب في هذا الموضوع وكذلك
بمتابعه من وزاره الخارجيه والممثله كذلك
الشكر لسفيرنا سائد الردايده ومحمد
الطراونه للقنصل وكافه الاخوان واللي هو
رئيس الجاليه كذلك واحنا ايضا نشكرهم
جميعا الحمد لله
يعني فعلا بدون ذكر اسماء كذلك والله ما
قصروا لغايه ما وصلنا الى هنا ولم ياللو
اي جهد في هذا الموضوع ان شاء الله الحمد
لله الاحترام والتقدير شكرا سيدي بارك
الله فيك شكرا انا بس بحاول اسمع شهادات
اخرى من الاخوان الحمد لله على سلامتك
حضرتك اردني من اي مدينه احنا من مدينه
الخرطوم من الخرطوم نعم انا طبعا الحمد
لله بفضل الله كنت المشرف على عمليه
الاجلاء احنا شركه البهاوس كنا المخدم في
عمليه اجلاء المواطنين الاردنيين من
الخرطوم الى بورسودا طيب عدد الباصات كانت
سبع باصات ممتاز بدي تحكي لي كانسان انت
كنت عايش هناك بصرف النظر عن اي شيء ايش
ايش اللي شفته انتم يعني لديكم مشاهدات
حيه مما يحدث هناك
راينا الحرب راينا الصواريخ راينا الناس
الذي تموتون راينا الجثث كثيره في الشوارع
لم
جثه هذه جميعها في الخرطوم تحديدا في شارع
المطار في شارع عبيد ختم في شارع الستين
هذه ابرز اسماء الشوارع التي كانت يوجد
فيها احداث معارك حقيقيه الرصاص كان ياتي
من فوق رؤوسنا دائما
كنا كثيرا يعني لا نستطيع ان نرجع الى
بيوتنا نضطر الى ان نجلس عند اخرين من اجل
ان نحافظ
طيب الطريق من من الخرطوم الى بورسودان
بمرورا بمدني كيف كانت خطيره خطيره جدا
واجهتنا كثير من المصاعب
لدرجه ان كثير من الاليات
ما بين الدعم السريع واليات الجيش كانت
موجوده على الطرقات
مشاهد مرعبه جدا لا يستطيع تخيلها احد
ربما يعني انا
اثقل قال انه
انت في عمليات سلب وعمليات ناب كانت تحدث
بجوز ما بعرف اذا تقدر تجاوبني بس من
الجهه التي كانت تفعل ذلك انت الان خارج
السودان وليس نحن لا نعرف لانهم في
النهايه هم كلهم يلبسون زي عسكري
لا نستطيع لكن
نحن بصفتنا كنا نعرف ان هذا دعم سريع او
هذا الجيش لكن لم نكن نحسم ان هذا دعم
سريع او جيش ممتاز انا بدي اهنيك على
سلامتك انت وكل الاردنيين ونتمنى طبعا انه
العافيه وانه الامور في السودان تكون على
خير ما يرام الحمد لله على السلامه سيدي
حضرتك اردني اهلا وسهلا من اي مدينه جئت
جئت من الخرطوم من الغضارف
زمان انت عايش في الخرطوم لا انا سايق
براد تمام يعني انت كنت صدفه هناك مثلا في
عمل كنت في سائق براد انقل بضائع من سوريا
او الاردن على السودان يعني انت ذهبت في
عمل وعلقت هناك بسبب الاحداث طيب ايش شفت
ايش شهادتك على اللي شفته هناك من معارك
شفت شيء من هاي المعارك
شفت شفت قصف عشوائي
وسلب وسرقات نعم حتى موثق عندي على
التلفون عندك فيديوهات واحد
طيب فعلا شوف الجثثها في الطرقات
كنت في حاله رعب انت يبدو انا حاسك زي
المظلوم او يعني اول مره واحد يشوف حرب
هيك يعني الواقع
على شاشات القنوات بس اول مره يعني نشوف
يعني
اخواننا سالتهم عن نسبه الامان في السودان
اليوم قالوا لي غير امنه تماما هذا يؤسفنا
ولكن يعني انت ايش رايك بهذا غير امنه حتى
هم يعني بالوقت الحالي صاروا الطريق اللي
انا بعيده صار يحفروا الطريق عشان
السيارات تهدي ويسلبوها يعني اشخاص يسلبوا
السيارات على الطريق من خرطوم الى بور
سودان بحفر الشارع يعملوا حفر كبيره عشان
السياره جباره توقف وقوف تام وانهانوا
عليها بالسلب مثلا نعم هذا رايتم ولا
سمعته عنه لا صار
ت صارت قدامنا قدامنا يعني
أنا طبعا على انك مرهق ومتعب وانا اسف اني
غلبتك الحمد لله على السلامه يعني نحن
سعداء برجوعك الى الاردن الحمد لله على
السلامه ميسون نعم الشهادات كثيره
تحياتي الحمد لله على السلامه حضرتك
اردنيه
مش حابه تحكي المهم انه الحمد لله على
السلامه انك بخير وهاي طفلتك الحمد لله
على سلامتكم الحمد لله على السلامه سيدي
حضرتك سوداني
الاردني اهلا وسهلا من اين من الخرطوم من
الخرطوم طيب انا بعرف انكم جميعا مرهقين
ولكن احنا مضطرين نسمع شهاداتكم لانه
الفرصه ان نلتقيكم الان ايش ايش يحكي لنا
شو اللي شفتوه من هناك من القصف المعارك
ايش اللي قاعد بصير لا المعارقه كنا
بيوتنا يعني ما طلعنا بالمعارك ولا
تسمعوا قصفوا
اشتباه
طريق من الطريق من الخرطوم الى بورتسودان
كيف كانت
كويس يعني الحمد لله
معروفين يعني الاردن معروف في خدمته
اقصد اقصد انه الطريق امن ولا كان في بعض
مشاكل
من الخرطوم يعني 30 40
كيلو في المحله قريب ومحلل اي بس لكن بعد
ما طلعنا من هناك بشويه بس قالوا لنا
دخلنا في العمان اه يعني انتم واجهتوا
خطوره بعد 30 او 40 كيلو من الخرطوم
باتجاه مدني وباتجاه باب سودان صحيح
لاداري بس الدرب الاول اللي كان ابتداوا
العصارات موجوده في الطريق يعني اثار
القصف والمعارك الحمد لله على السلامه وان
شاء الله نتمنى لسودان ان يعود الامور
مستتبه في وبامان ان شاء الله قريبا الحمد
لله على السلامه حبيبي انت الحمد لله على
سلامتك من وين جيت من اي مدينه جيت من
الخرطوم انت والعائله انا معي اهلي مقيمين
هناك مقيمين كنتم قريبين من مكان القصف
ايش شفتوا هناك احكيلنا بالمطار وكل يوم
والله رصاص ضرب رصاص قوي كثير قنابل
والله هي اول ما بلشت اصلا كنا نسافر يوم
احد فصارت الحرب
طيارات جنب بيتنا بيجوا قنابل ودخلت ثلاث
رصاصات على البيت عبيتكم اه الحمد لله بس
طلع ما في الحمد لله الحمد لله الحمد لله
يعني
انت قريب من منطقه المطار ايوه
[موسيقى]
لما طلعنا من البيت قال ان الجيش سيطر على
المطار
وعملوا هدنه بس ما التزموا فيها واحنا
والله قدرنا نطلع اذا صاحب يعني معاه
سياره كويسه
وقدرنا نطلع ايش شفتوا على الطريق ايش
اسمك حضرتك اسمي محمد محمد ايش شفته على
الطريق والله كان في ارتكازات للدعم
السريع
كانوا واقفين بالشارع يعني وصار يهددو فيه
طلقتين بالهواء وبس ما لما شاف ان السفر
الاردنيه ما حكوا شي بخوفوا يعني ايوه
شفتوا اثار قصف معارك وانتم ماشيين شفتوا
جثث مثلا جثث لا انا بس شفت في عماره
والله في شارع منطقه شارع اسمه شارع
الستين في عماره وقعت عليها قذيفه مضبوط
صح في هناك شفناها والله شفناها بعنايه
وفي فيديو مصور بس
بصراحه بجوز كان في خوف كبير وانت هناك
هلا كيف حاسس لا هسا الحمد لله طمنت لما
شفت جيش الله يحفظهم ما شاء الله
اطمن انت يعني
ايوه دخلت الحمد لله على السلامه الله
يحفظ لك اهلك وان شاء الله نتمنى للسودان
ان تعود اليه وهو امن ان شاء الله لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات